Thank You counsel as I believe we should
now be live-streaming I thank you for
that henna good afternoon to elected
members in staff into our public who are
out there watching our livestream today
of the meeting of committee of Council
today the 4th of May in as you will be
well aware we are conducting this
meeting by audio visual link via the
platform of zooms so I would call for
any apologies I believe his worship is
having some technical difficulties and
we're waiting on him to get in to the
meeting and I see counts the heat is not
with us this afternoon any other
apologies from anyone I think anyone
happy to move those apologies out there
please
Vicki counselor Everett seconded by
Councillor Ludlow all those in favor if
you just want to give me a we raise our
the right hand fear or your thumb emoji
thank you against carries Thank You
counselors interest register as you know
very basic if anything needs to be
changed on net that information needs to
go through our administration team and
I'll move to item 3 which is the minutes
of our last meeting held on the 28th of
April I take it that those minutes have
been reared there's anyone happy to move
that we receive those minutes
Vicki Catholic Clark seconded by
Councillor Lewis any discussion on those
minutes
thank you all those in favor of those
minutes being adopted please raise your
right hand
accepted
all those against you've still got your
thumbs up the emojis great thank you
I'm take that my string is moved sorry
is being passed it'll move straight to
item number four on the agenda today
what counsel a bit or can i apologies i
believe those minutes should be
confirmed as a true and correct record
unusual for a committee but this
committee has a wide range of powers and
the minutes of this committee at this
time stay with this committee so if you
your mover and seconder could adjust
accordingly great mover and seconder
happy with it and all those in favor
thank you Carrie
um guys I'm just wanting to bring to
your attention before we do move into
item number 4 which I failed to remember
a major late item
I'll ask clear to speak to their item
and then ask if there's a moment in
seeking to who would would like to move
that we accept the major late item it is
in relation to crown infrastructure so I
will it clear lead out on that one
Thanks council battle for the purposes
of understanding what you're being asked
to vote on in terms of the major late
item I received in the early hours of
the morning a request for further
information from crown and for structure
partners for all of the five
shovel-ready projects that council has
put forward the nature of the
application and such that they are
looking for clarity over the funding
assistance and other types of assistance
sort that needs to be back by five
o'clock tonight officers of during the
meeting in order that they can talk
through each of those applications but I
ask that you receive that oral update is
a major later item if you can't select
Abbott anyone here just seeking it that
we accept the major late item counselor
Clark is it a question or are you
accepting I'll take that counselor claps
and move by counts and they're in
seconded by Councillor clack that we
accept the late item all those in favor
please raise your right hand in when it
comes to discussion we will obviously go
through that process of questions thank
you team so we'll move to item number
four which is on our agenda yes I also
have a late item as well and I'd like to
address some of the issues that are
sitting around the dispute that the PSA
has a council thank you capsule attack
um can you just give us a wee bit more
detail about that so we know what we are
voting to accept in I'm happy to put
that motion to the table sure there's
been a considerable amount of media
exposure and a lot of commentary on
online Facebook and other social media
things about a dispute that was reported
in the paper and reported by the PSA and
so I have some unanswered issues that I
would like to explore the chief
executive to find out we were at and
certainly where we're at with the legal
position that needs to be gathered on
that I think he council attack I'm just
gonna ask for some guidance around later
item considering we are talking about
staff I just want to make sure that we
are able to do that in this forum and if
so I will be happy to put that motion
out for anyone to move in second is
there anyone that can give us that
information
chief executive council apparel my
advice what to counsel would be that it
is not a matter for council ticket
discounts however I also recognize that
at times councils like to understand
more and in the event that council chose
to seek some dialogue around it it was a
matter that should be in public excluded
Thank You Council clack are you happy
for that
to be pop into public excluded can you
speak to that please
certainly yep I think I've already tried
to raise the issues and a public
excluded meeting which is their last
executive leadership team meeting and
that was closed down by the chief
executive so it's already been in the
media there's been a lot of commentary
online about it it doesn't require to go
back into closed session
I'm not understood and in any way
attacking or confronting any staff
member I just want to get to the bottom
of the issues that we're facing around
the allegations by the PSA thank you so
can I take it from that that you are
happy for it to stay in public you'd
like to move that we pop that motion
into public look great
thank you counts because this has been
brought to my attention now I'm what I'm
going to do is the chair is request that
we have a seconder to have that
discussion first of all and then I'm
going to ask for some questions if this
is appropriate
so my first call would be if we have a
seconder to have this discussion in
public is there a second to move that
motion from our table okay a councillor
Clark I would be happy to see connect
motion if the discussion would be in
public excluded I think that's fear in
relation to
councillors elected members staff and
our our staff and obviously staff there
at the table so I am happy to do that
can I just have any questions please so
I need to know from you council o'clock
if you would like that discussion to be
had in public excluded today well
obviously if there's no option to do it
in a public manner so that the community
you can see what's going on and into the
bottom of some of these issues then I
guess the other option on god is to go
to public school and I'm gonna have to
ask the staff now that the motion has a
move that in Sikandar sorry they're
elected members that we bring this to
the council with a late item and public
excluded so if we're happy to we've got
to move it in Sikandar council to clamp
myself seconding that motion that we
have a conversation in regards to this
in public excluded all those counselors
that are in favor of accepting this as a
late item please raise your right hand
to the Kim rap nice and clearly okay so
I take it that that motions be lost
sorry council o'clock we'll have to move
on from the air and I move to item
number four on the agenda I'm sorry
counselor Biddle but for the time I need
to ask for the item on shovel-ready
projects to be considered first surely
they just take that item first oh I'll
take that item first and then we will
move to number four yeah just because
I'm a bit confused you know benefits
throw me councillor clack it would be
good to be notified in future of any
late items coming to the table so I
consider its Jia yeah actually can be
accepted or not in that saves everyone
from a very uncomfortable and awkward
position that we've been put in today
however I take take your concern counsel
Clark it's been raised in obviously the
emotions fallen short today
can I please ask Lenny if we've moved in
seconded accepting the infrastructure
late item yes great
okay council opatija can you just give
me a nod is this question in relation to
the late item that's been put on the
table or the motion that's just fallen
short the other letter okay so I'm gonna
just forget it
at the moment so we can get back to
business in if we have time we will go
back to today count the square thank you
clear I'll let you take the floor and
give us the motion sorry madam chair and
I just remind if I could take
councillors back the government the
crown Infrastructure Partners asked if
we had shovel-ready projects the
applications needed to be in by the
Tuesday immediately after Easter I think
it was the 14th of April we had a
capture on that morning in order to
consider the priority for those
shovel-ready projects at that stage we
were just put in the projects forward
and the projects went forward in the
priority area of firstly the city center
secondly the stock Bank at State Street
thirdly the bluff master plan fourth was
water and fifth was the civic
administration building I'm now going to
ask the staff that are the project
leaders for each of those to briefly
outline the total for the project cost
in the funding that we are putting
forward that we are seeking at the end
madam chair it would be helpful if
council was to or committee was to
endorse the approach that has been taken
so that's the resolution
would be looking for at the end so
Andrew if we could lead out with the
city center block button thank you so
the sum of all the projects that were
put forward for the inner city block had
a total capital spending of around 270
million dollars when we reviewed that
and had a look at the different sources
of funding that were going to be
available and the different options that
were presented by the government as to
how they might assist in ensuring that
those projects go ahead we ended up
coming up with a request for a sum of 83
million in the end and that's comprised
some grant money and some effectively
commercial loan from the government and
that's really to have a look at removing
the risks associated with the current
uncertainty and what that might cause in
terms of the ability of the project to
go forward thank you Andrew
I think I'm going to ask questions is we
going so there's no confusion if it's
okay
councillor Emmett yeah what's the value
of the commercial line in there
so we had some discussion around that
and we thought in the end in discussion
with the the directors and and everyone
else that the best way to go around that
was to look at replacing the bank
essentially so for a short period of
time we see some risks around the the
bank funding around some of the
conditions and so we thought the most
appropriate way I was to have a look at
seeing whether or not we could get some
assistance from the government to
replace the bank in the short term
effectively so 50 million 53 is what the
bank was was in for subject the terms
and conditions of their loan thank you
any further questions please counselor
Pottinger
oh yeah following on from Chancellor
ever the percentage the sort of the
interest rate of the loan
now that would vary from what the bank
was going to give us secretary there's
two options from the Infrastructure Fund
and they've got effectively a
concessional loan which which is not at
commercial terms whatever you might want
to define that as but most people would
jump to the right and there's commercial
terms again in fairness to everyone at
this stage were put in for a commercial
loan because really the the budget and
the project was funded on that basis
it's really the uncertainty we see
around some of the criteria for for
drawing down those funds more so than
the terms in terms of the interest rate
themselves so to answer your question or
that a bit vague in the world we have a
choice there's an option to do either
and obviously that is something that
would be discussed down the track but at
this stage where the the intention of
this stage is to go to the commercial
but if there was a obviously a direction
or a feeling that we should go something
else that's open at this stage it's
unclear basically I imagine this is just
a general indication as to how you want
to approach it and I suspect the
concessional loan is probably more a
midway between a grant and alone whereas
we're saying we'd like a grant and just
the the commercial loan to sort of deal
with the other issue okay and who makes
that decision is that is that council or
is that going to be the CBD committee
the actual company its councils
application so if you said today that
you thought we should apply for a
concession alone then presumably that's
something that we would at a bare
minimum listen to but first month most
likely follow but the thinking is is as
I've explained it as to why we've gone
away at ease
okay no that's fine because the the
actual company itself would have been
hand hand
the original date line that we were
going for correct and the ends would
still so this is a effectively whilst
that counsels running a lead on and it's
a joint application with the company
that's carrying out the development no
that's fine thanks Andrew Thank You
councillor Pottinger thank you enjoy it
any further questions Andrew I do
because I'm a bit confused so I'm going
to have to ask it might be a silly
question I'm sorry the concession line
so what you're saying is they instead of
going to the bank or the company going
to the bank to borrow the money we are
going to request this funding from the
infrastructure fund under Council and
we're going to ask them for it to be
funded or loaned is that correct it is
the total amount that we're asking 83
million all 53 so the total amount is 83
33 million dollars whether that is a
grant to make up for grants that we
otherwise don't think will get in to
assist council a contribution towards
the Porsche and the council's already
committed to put in the loan amount is
is to effectively replace the bank loan
in the short term I wouldn't expect and
a lot of these things are still
uncertain at this stage but but I don't
expect it would be like a bank loan that
you would roll over from time to time if
the government goes down that path they
would be considering things like a short
term failure in the system that they
need to bridge a gap for so I suspect it
would just be a short-term loan and
there being probably an expectation that
we would fund that from the bank
sometime shortly in the future in May
can I ask what they advanced i mean
clearly the advantage of a 33 million
dollar grant are self-explanatory they
saw something that we would have to pay
back but the advantages of doing it this
way than the other basically what you're
looking at is a slight variation on the
commercial terms as to why you might be
able to draw the loan down there might
be without going into sort of commercial
realities which probably isn't
appropriate in a public forum but there
might be reasons why the markets
Eiling which means you can't drawdown
that bank loan for some reason so just
removes the risk that whilst you've got
the ability to borrow from a bank for
some reason you can't get all that money
at this stage but the expectation will
be that in the short to medium term you
would be able to draw that money down
from the bank thank you and there's no
additional resting Council as a result
of doing it this way the loan itself
will be taken out by the company so
there's no change in risk and profile
from that perspective but obviously
ultimately counsels a shareholder in
that company obviously it would do risk
to the thing that there's any grand it
reduces councils exposure to the moment
so that produces the risk thank you in
any other questions for mr. Cameron no
we'll just move on to the next project
thank you
Jeremy if you'd like to Cheers
yep um thank you
clear it's the next one we've got on
there is the steed Street stop bank it's
actually a combination of a number of
projects between ourselves and
environment Southland particular status
Street stop bank the way the Cobb Road
stopped being which ties into that why
Hopis a noted punic stop thanks for
environment Southlands shared use path
back towards the airport and the State
Street pump station so all of those
together 20 2.7 million being ICC's
portion of that is 15 and a half million
and 7.2 being the balance from
environment Southland at the moment
we're looking at a funding request of
8.8 million and that's effectively five
five million funding for ourselves our
environment Southland are looking at 50
percent of their funding of their
portion and so there'll be a question
for committee as to whether or not we
look at asking for 50 percent of our
portion as well which would take it to
11.35 been half of the total project
yeah Thank You Jeremy a clarification
that's the joint project with
environment Southland and you're
requesting that we take half of our
follow me on to our half or the amount
that you've suggested let's take a
better customer effort I think you might
have answered my question I was sort of
kindess leader to environments Elfman
with 50% of their 7.2 and I believe that
we should be 50% of our 15
any further questions counselors anyone
just so you've got some leeway Jeremy
what what's the question you would like
to ask us to maybe give you some
guidance on here is it whether we take
the 50% yeah I think yeah that would be
its really assuming we would match the
request from environment Southland for
50% of the funding which would make it
11.35 million request and title which
would put us on par with environment
Southland request but that's where I was
coming from do you need a motion on that
clear I don't I don't think we need a
motion we're just some guidance around
then is it creeps me I'm happy that
that's considered an undertaking and
we'll get to the end and endorse a lot
thank you that's the clarification the
in before we move on the expectation is
that we would be requesting 11.35
million which is exactly the same as
environment self is everyone happy with
that if you are just give me a wee wave
of the hand so we're on the same train
beautiful Thank You team great and we'll
move out to your next to Alistar it's
okay
it's good afternoon counselors we put an
application totaling fifteen point eight
million were four parts to that the
ranks on pipeline renewal which councils
may be aware of was the main player in
that just a step take it step backwards
all the components have actually been
signaled in the long term plan so those
were projects that were going to go
ahead anyway out of that fifteen point
eight eleven point two five million is
associated with the young-ran song
pipeline so we elected at a this
morning's discussion to just promote the
breaks home pipeline as a project we
wanted funding for and the consensus of
a meeting was that a third of that cost
would be reasonable to apply for in
terms of a grant we felt that was the
best the best chance of succeeding in
getting a grant make it too large and we
probably would be struck off so it was a
subjective decision that term what we're
asking councilors to endorse is the
application for a grant of three point
seven five million dollars towards the
ranks whole pipeline renewal project
Thank You Alastair any questions for
Alastair around this particular project
in the amount this we're being asked to
endorse councillor Clark Musil sir just
one issue which was the issue of the
alternative water supply and I've seen
some papers recently that suggested that
we were looking to all tenders and one
of the options for treatment of an
alternative water supply was to bring it
through the Brinks home system as
opposed to having a shipper plan will it
change what you're intending to do in
this this project
no that's counselor Clark I can speak to
that later on in this meeting when the
update for the emergency water supply
it's four we put forward to the meeting
men but as I understand it the
shovel-ready projects are really meant
for projects that are going to happen in
the next 12 months now the development
of a emergency water supply is not
scheduled till halfway through this
decade around about 2025 so in terms of
the timeframe it the development cost is
not to be considered I mentioned earlier
that the total package I had put forward
the consideration was initially 15.8
made up of four components and there was
a small component and that for the
alternative water supply to complete the
investigation works something less than
three hundred thousand dollars but that
has dropped off we took the oppor to an
getting phones from the government and
terms of a grant that's money from the
crown we're bitter to tone air set our
sights a little bit lower and aim for
the brakes on pipeline contribution
which is by far the most significant
project we have in the next year or so
thank you thank you if you can look back
thank you Alistair any further questions
great thank you I'm not sure that I'm
seeing everyone so I'll give it as go is
it Jane or Pete I'm not really sure was
so clear I might ask you to lidia I
think Michelle hasn't had the
opportunity to drop that bluff yet so
let's hear from her
thank you clear so the bluff master plan
project is another shovel-ready
application the the project actually
consists of a series of projects all
through which the bluff master plan
which is not yet finalized but it's
getting close to it they all fall within
their that master plan and this
application has been made on behalf of
the community board who are well
involved in the project so projects
include and the key ones I'll mention
are the vocabulary way and the bluff
program in particular there are some
other more minor projects including
information kiosk development some
recreation precinct improvements and
others so this project comes to a value
of eleven point seven million dollars
and with a deficit of seven million
however we are proposing a grant of four
point one five million and we see as
allister's alluded to we see there is an
amount that it will give us the best
chance of succeeding through this
process so so we've done some
calculations believe it will give us the
best chance but it also means that we'll
be able to get this project moving
thank you Thank You aunt Michelle
council a clap yeah Michelle just on the
issue of the volumes that are involved
now I thought that the baseline criteria
for the crown infrastructure projects
where the project had to be more than
more than ten million dollars so are you
suggesting that the projects are still
worth eleven point seven but it's just
that we're seeking a lower amount by way
of a grant does that be saying so the
total project value is eleven point
seven million dollars now we've already
secured four point seven million we're
requesting four point one five million
and we will need to if we will need to
top that additional amount up either
through additional council contribution
or other grants but the project can
still proceed and with that minimum
amount Thank You council o'clock does it
answer your question Thank You Michelle
and clear moving on to your next project
from oh thank you very much and good
afternoon councillors so the renewal
work on the civic administration
building is being put in the long-term
plan for two and three years away at a
value of 50 essaouira Young at point
three million dollars we've done a very
recent restoration of that and looked at
what we want to do should I say that
eight point three also included
renovation we're got about two or three
of the floors but not the whole building
so we've looked at what would be
involved in renovation of the whole
building as part of this
recent restart came to 15.6 million
dollars so we've we've looked at
applying for a grant of one third of
there through the shovel-ready project
so that would mean that we'd be making a
grand application of five million
dollars in this case
but that was to be the case then the
amount and the long-term plan of 8.3
still stood then we be looking at doing
a small readjustment to the total to of
something like the 30 million dollar
bill than the administration building
the advantage we see for the
shovel-ready projects in this case is
that the work can start in a fairly
short period of time and it would give a
lot of work to local trades people and
then doing the renovation work such as
carpenters electricians plumbers and so
on and that would be a venue to smaller
contractors in the city Thank You mr.
Horner just a question for you my
understanding was that project never
made it through the first phase so can
we just have an update on that if
someone can
as I understand it it was but then I
didn't attend that meeting I just
understood that it was the lowest things
going on here Paul counts so at the
counselor catch up the projects were
prioritized and the CA B was first
counselor Biddle's referring to some
informal advice I got about the projects
that had or had not gone forward it
would seem that irrespective of what
we've been told about what has or has
not gone forward we have received this
request in relation to all projects it's
great so get out come thank you any
other questions for mr. Horner okay
thanks time um clear who's next on the
list have we got one network no madam
chair Betts the lot and I think that you
asked for just a brief round up so
Andrew talked about 33 million dollars
in grants and a 50 million dollar
concessionary lon
Jeremy talked about the steep steep
flood Bank and total project cost of
about 23 mils so it was agreed to go
through 50 percent eleven and a half
million the bluff master plan is looking
for four point one five million Anna's
just spoke about focusing on the brain
storm water pipe replacement on the
basis that that work could be
consolidated into a shorter period and
we were looking for a third or three
point seven five million and 5 million
for the Civic admin building
thank you clear appreciate that
councillors I'll ask you now if you
would like to endorse if we could ever
move it and asleep and to endorse these
projects please think you council and
lowest council o'clock seconded any
questions for the discussion on this
just one Thank You counselor but he okay
I was just thinking about the civic
administration building and what Paul
said about the local environment did
local people tradesmen that would be
applicable across all but these events
are at the priorities would be given to
our local people um councilor Biddle if
I respond to that on behalf of everyone
I think the point that Paul was really
making was that it was a different type
of contractor that would be involved a
met to the other projects I think it
highly likely that we'd be looking to
utilize local contractors and I would
also flag to you that the government is
saying that part of the response they'd
like to see from us is a different
approach to procurement so you can
expect to hear more from that if we are
successful in getting any of this
funding Thank You councillor thank you
for that response clear and councilors
it's obvious that we have an opportunity
and a good one at that so we'll put that
motion that's been moved and seconded
that we endorse these projects it will
generate more capital to be done quicker
and hopefully a lot more jobs for our
people in our community who are facing
some pretty tough times so I'll put that
motion all those in favor please raise
your right hand
all those against
they contain motion carries already for
some reason I hear you've been kicked
out of my agenda on the computer so we
will move to the next item which was
item 4 from memory of the agenda please
Creek me if I'm wrong and I will ask
clear or who me but please I got to
speak to that please council Abimelech
just confirm we're talking about direct
costly legacy and that would be Michele
Ron thank you that's great I think you
canceled a battle and councilors so this
item is as you'll be aware director
Stello
sadly passed away last year and late
last year he left a legacy of $90,000 to
Invercargill City and as well he stated
one part to the EM Vicario City Council
for community projects within the
auditory area into community after a
lengthy consideration and thank you to
councillors Clark and Arnold for hosting
the community meeting on the 11th of
February after extensive consultation
with our own staff looking at a
strategic direction and reflecting the
interests of Dura Costello as much as we
could find out about him we have made a
recommendation that the Bergquist should
be spent on one specific significant
project in that being phosphine de park
enhancements those enhancements include
a comprehensive barbecue structure and
complimentary facilities that go along
with that as well as some amenity
planting and other improvements like
seating but that will be it assuming the
extent of the budget so determining how
far that goes yeah so thank you Thank
You Michelle um I take it that the
reports been read by everybody and it
was a
comprehensive report sir thank you for
this I have a question from counselor
Arnold
anyone else might raise some questions
here capital the Arnold ending counselor
clack thank you good afternoon I was
just looking at the report and I noticed
that just that I spend a lot of his time
walking around an audit are always
looking for seats to sit on and I was
just thinking for something a bit more
permanent than perhaps required a little
bit this maintenance going forward could
be possibly have been parked benches or
something strategically placed around
the tariff or people that do walk around
and a lot of people do walk around here
for people to actually sit on and
Calissa if you build a barbecue it
possibly into Park which is to be fear
uzuki and then the cow GOPAC not know
the Tara Park it's not really padded by
the terrorists as the Sandy Point domain
I was just thinking that you do not need
to get one group of people were using it
using it at a particular time so so the
users will be a lot more limited so I'll
be thinking that's it you know just in
my view pipe inches might be a better
option that's just a thought
thought Michelle Thank You counselor so
thank you I appreciate those comments
and we have thought long and hard about
about this one and the calming of seats
has come up because I am conscious that
he did walk around the community a lot
my view is this a one significant
project which the phosphine don't park
enhancements it would include a number
of seating arrangements so I wouldn't
expect it to be limited to one one
family I do feel it that one significant
project would be a would maximize the
$90,000 towards a single project and be
a given therefore given more
significance I do feel that maybe
park benches around o Tutera may get
lost
however I would also be willing to have
a conversation about if they are park
benches missing and in and around Oh
Tutera I would I would love to hear
about it too but I still am of the view
that phosphene the park is the
appropriate location I think she
Michelle counselor clapping and I'll go
back to counselor because I see that he
wanted to raise a question of that is it
right counselor not you're gonna count
some o'clock first and come back to
counseling I don't know thank you for
presenting its paper and I don't support
the one project concept counselor myself
took quite a bit of time and effort to
consult with the owner tolerant
community about what they wanted about
18 or 19 suggestions for the use of the
legacy were thrown up we had a public
meeting and we condense it down to about
12 interesting to note that the the foss
bender BBQ suggesting was actually 12th
on our list of 12 so priority wise
that's not hard for for the community I
don't agree also with the concept that
councils coming from that part of the
legacy could not be gifted away funding
to a couple of three organizations that
operate within Otara one is the land
care group that does a lot of work
around land care and also does a lot of
work with promoting conservation and bio
mentalism with schoolchildren and the
other project is the bush haven that
rescues and rehabilitates damaged birds
in particular pigeons and two E's and so
I'm striving with both those contexts
and I guess high up on our list was also
the need for a noted and you owe doTERRA
sign could also acknowledge Derek's gift
so I guess a little bit in opposition to
what's being proposed I would prefer to
have a range of four or five on projects
in certainly
the grants to the bush haven was
actually at the top of Ellis because we
felt that was a small voluntary group
that needed some help building cages for
the damaged birds Thank You councillor
plaque I'm going to move to councillor
Arnold
I've got cats on my sofa I have got
counts on a cricket in councilor Lewis
so if you just take your lead from the
previous councillor that would be great
yeah just back to you Michelle
I just noticed them the thing existed
one barbecue you never mentioned more
seats Pat stood only one barbecues and
the sort of seating else I was thinking
of personally was something in relation
similar to what you'd have in Queens
Park but you're a concrete and permanent
and don't get moved around I'm also
probably more supportive of what
Chancellor Clark's mentioning the year
as well because being at the meeting and
the in hearing what the people did
actually want it was SSA yam
the faustina thing was number 12 on the
last year Thank You councillor Soper
thanks Madame Chia I've given quite a
bit of thought to this legacy from the
from the point of view of a lawyer in
the first principle of a lawyer drawing
up wills and I I hasten to say I didn't
have anything to do with drawing up this
world but I have drawn up several other
wills as that the be carrying out of the
intentions of the person who made the
world counts for a great deal and
there's an absolute responsibility I was
therefore quite concerned when I started
to see suggestions about gifting any
part of this legacy to other trusts that
are well-known in the auditory area and
I hasten to say I support those trusts
that have been named but it is very
obvious to me from a legal perspective
that if mr. Costello had wanted such a
legacy to be made
he would have actually written it in his
will and that for those trusts are very
well known and itit are mr. gostin I was
very long-term resident it would have
been a much plainer legal matter he had
wanted to donate to trusts for that to
have been put in the world as specific
crores as the thief that it isn't comes
back to him having gifted one part of
his estate to the endocardial City
Council for projects and it seems to me
that what where the ended up worth is
one distinct project
there's infect the best way to carry out
the intentions of what mr. Costello was
hoping for and as well as something that
I that enhance the the Otero community
in wasn't lying with the things that he
was involved in in his life so I'm very
comfortable with the recommendations and
I would be quite concerned at giving any
part of that legacy and a form that mr.
Costello did not intend his loan to
allow thank you Hey he kept sinless oppa
I think that's the cricket in the Loess
[Music]
we could take and just re-gift it and my
second question was around since we had
this community consultation meeting and
this proposal was put forward as to what
the community wanted to do with this
money I was a question of Michelle
really is too if we strike out the the
donations to the different Trust's the
second order of priority is the bike
training area for children I was just
wondering why that wasn't thought to be
included thank you so I guess I come
back to Derrick Costello's
and trust so we spent a quite a bit of
time trying to learn about him and his
interests and we we understood that he
enjoyed walking and spending time
exploring so we felt that this boss
bender Park project was more in keeping
with his desires we also I guess I'm
aware of Sandy Point and the relative
proximity of Sandy point to the Otero
community and the fact that there is a
bike pump track within close proximity
as well as the mountain biking here area
so those were all factors that were
considered Thank You Michele thinking
council approved councilor Lewis Thank
You deputy me I concur with that
counselor cipher and also council
crackered of course and Michele be on
page 18 and port books the conclusion
really summed up through the discussions
of of his lawyer the recommendation be
spent a month significant protic because
apparently he indicated through his will
and that was really confirmed through
discussions with the lawyer I have not
been privy to the lawyer or the will of
course but that really sums it up there
should be spent on one project I respect
the input the council of Clark and
councillor Hahn will put in whether the
public discussion and also of course the
will or discussion results from the
public discussion but when it boils down
to it if the will and Fiat or his lawyer
had had discussions with the gentlemen
then perhaps we should abide by that
discussion thank you thank you I just
have a question of Michelle or two
probably and Michelle how did you learn
about mr. Goss the right pronunciation
and I feel that it's not and who was it
that you spoke to in relation to getting
some information about him
was interesting sexual work and seeking
me true counselor Arnold I think cancer
clerk may be able to answer the question
around the projects within the printout
that you gave us from the meeting with
the community how many of those would
would fit into mr. Guster those wishes
okay yeah so the first question so I had
a actually a staff member connect with
the mr. Costello's lawyer and I'm not
sure this is the appropriate forum for
him to go to specific names at this
point but it was a direct conversation
with mr. Costello's lawyer and that was
we we did spend quite a lot of time
trying to understand more about mr.
Costello so that was our best shot is it
- so thank you much Joe that's very
helpful
counselor Clark or Arnold counselor
plaque can you answer my second question
is one that person you mean Tony I just
would like to know after you spoke to
the entire community what projects will
be relevant to custom oh gosh and you
omit specific list that you gave us from
the community of road attack sure I
think I think the more relevant ones for
us and the ones that came up and high up
on our list if you take the other
donations and it comes up number two on
ALS was the issue of how many new
overtire sign something that might be in
metal type construction like you see at
bluff which is quite outstanding and the
part of that could acknowledge Derrick's
donation to the community so I'd still
like to see that their respect or
whether we go to faust be in the park
and I guess the other issues that came
up was quite a strong demand to
upgrade the school pool which needs some
significant work done on and and its
fundraising already there but to help
there I think would it would help in
some ways keeping the local children
active at the moment the schools not
good and the school pools not in good
shape and so but if we if we're getting
down to just one one project and I don't
want to limit it just to one but it was
one project I guess the real issue will
be the issue do we do the eau de tar
reserve do we do the bushy point do we
do Faust bender and to me it makes not a
lot of difference which project we do to
that but I think given that we've got
90,000 it wouldn't be a unreasonable to
put ten thousand towards a a really
spectacular sign that leans in Toyota
time the one that's currently there is
made of wood and it's really falling
apart
Thank You councillor Claire accounts an
appalling jar um right a couple of
couple issues talk about what may be the
intention of mr. Costello was the
walking bit is quite important and I
think everyone would recognize the
amount of people walking over the last
month it's like they're seen from one of
those apocalypse movies where everyone's
out and it's quite amazing and and
without a doubt possibly in a park feeds
into some of the most amazing walking
tracks around you know whether you call
it Sandy pointer out of terror I mean to
me it's owner Terence the same thing
you've got sort of naturally formed
forest tracks that change occasionally
and people explore those and they go all
over the place you've got the wind rose
lift by the price three people and you
go round and round around and it's
amazing place and it's a good off dog
area - you've got a great car park
across Linda Park and then you've also
got kill mark track which is the
beautiful
we formed Bush walk right in the heart
of that area and that's amazing there's
truly like a premium walk that you can
do and I think the whole phosphene part
whether it's whether it's you know nice
paved entry or was the gravel entrance
it's got good parking it now has the
fence the fence thing to start pones
getting onto the grass area to destroy
that you talk about black area for kids
to learn that can be done in there I'm
not I mean the barbecue is one of those
things that can be added anytime but
that within fostering the park you could
have a legacy recreation area and memory
of this man but for the donating this
money I don't I don't think the sign is
something that if you finally if 90,000
and someone said I a ringing you know
you you money was gonna be used as a
sign and you mean over old I would not I
personally wouldn't be using it for that
at all that's something the City Council
can do and it's responsible for just
like we're way overdue of having our own
signs for the mechanic you'll see we've
been talking about there for ages so
that can go that Oh Tutera sign can go
on that list but I I think this whole
project at first bender can incorporate
so many great things and the Eau de
terre people they're the first off the
block to use this it's just down the
road we're talking about doing up the
grounds at Anderson's Park and it's
going to be obviously and be careful
people get out there and use it now for
owner Tara people this is either walk
down there we jump in your car in five
minutes um right behind in developing
this it's a brilliant part of Sandy
Point and offers so much for everyone so
yep I think it's a good idea and I mean
Michelle's gonna bring back a plan for
what they intend to do and we can look
at that and we still can still can
critique it and and massage
so yeah I'm right behind it thank you
cancel appalling jet and welcome to the
meeting you worship I believe if you had
technical difficulties I'm very pleased
to see you here today with us so that's
good and just for your reference we are
currently on the item number four which
is the legacy left by mr. Costello third
time lucky I hope I've got that name
Crete I counsel a clerk just as an
attorney to the one of the request for
information by one of my colleagues they
asked about what projects were in the
list that came from the from the
community group around walking and there
were three one was a new track food
bushy point second one was a an
extension of the eau de terre resume
which is opposite the shop that could be
extended to go out to Maremma north to
create a bit of loot there and then
there was the issue for spender Park and
I guess from my perspective I'm not sure
whether we need to start thinking about
having CCT CCTV in casa minha partly
that's a cost that we should necessarily
go to I think we better off spreading it
across two or three projects but
accepting that may be the the most
significant one is the phosphate the one
I think we can select clack
so with it you wouldn't you wish it
would you like to speak to this
particular item we quite hippie just
gather your thoughts there and catch up
to the next year so I'm just don't catch
Fri sure I'm the only problem is that
you hidden mr. Skelton says to you madam
chair and thank you Monsieur on for the
very extensive report just for a point
of clarification from councillor
honorable Clark thank you for having
that meeting which was interesting but
report of a clarification at the meeting
were the group the ratepayers group of
the group that would be
aware of the legal definition of the
literacy because that's actually the
intent is really important as we move
forward and the intent appears to be
legally that of one monumental whatever
it may be is an actual fact what would
be well from the intent of the little
would actually be where we need to go
was it explained to the group on the
councillor Arnold will Clark because I
think it's really important as we move
forward when one wants to leave a legacy
it's important that's there for time and
overtime and if you look at the examples
within the city there's some fantastic
legacies been left they look at the BRIT
monroe model looks they're outside the
gates and there's many many of them
around
I just think by decimating or
diminishing by having many projects it
diminishes the actual value of the
bequest to be honest $90,000 an awful
lot of money and we could do something
very very special as Michelle is
outlined there's been a lot of work done
on there and I think we need to be very
careful we don't move away from what
what actually is the intention of the
bequest and it's very clear legally it's
very clear legally that the one project
is the way to go so to help me was that
group made aware of that Thank You
councillor Scout Council Clark you know
I hear they're mean and no we didn't say
that it was exclude it was required b1
project and I see nothing on in this
paper the scissor has to be won that's
just a preference from Council the other
issue is what Leslie Soper raised that
had it been a gift to an organization
then mr. Costello man gifted there and I
chip there but at the time of doing that
we weren't aware of that and as the as
the report quite rightly said here the
money was gifted to counsel or counsel
to determine what happens but that is to
be applied to the entire area
community so we went into that meeting
assuming that we had a range of options
but we certainly didn't have any
understanding that that we really need
to focus on just one project in key
councillor Clark councillor sidebar and
then I'm going to ask for someone to
move
Sikandar seeking those motions thanks
madam sure I was actually going to offer
to move it on by moving the
recommendations is this thin thing he
was like to see in bit as you're a
seconder for that motion please
Thank You councillor amundson so the
motion has been moved and seconded I
just have one question before we do go
into there sorry I forgot that I can ask
questions too um my question is around
as true Michelle bearing in mind that we
have consulted the auditorium community
that has been done as per the decision
that was made by counsel Arnold and
councillor clack to go ahead and consult
the community is there any projects from
the consultation process that happen
with that community that could be
considered within the phosphene der
upgrades
I either walking tricks is part of that
whole holistic project there and frost
bender is something that we could
include or is that just a a very plain
phosphine de Park only so my
recommendation is for one project
however the phosphine de Park project in
itself can be developed further so that
could include walking tracks obviously
not at the auditory Reserve or bushi
point locations so it would be focused
on phosphine de and the reason for going
for Faust bender as opposed to bushy
point or Oda Terra comes back to that
leaving a legacy coming so we felt that
it Faust meter we could really leave a
legacy while the improvements to those
other parks would be beneficial they
wouldn't need
that they'd potentially dissolve into
the wider trail networking you wouldn't
see it you wouldn't you wouldn't see the
seed contribution so it was really the
the emphasis on Faustina and I guess
just to reiterate that's certainly not
an easy call to make on this
recommendation it could go any way but
but we've made a recommendation thank
you for that Michele
so with that in mind we have a mover and
a seconder for the motion that I'm just
trying to get on my computer that the
report obviously be received in a very
thorough report so thank you to staff
that Council approved the recommendation
that Derek Costello $90,000 be request
be spent on option three one significant
project which would be the phosphine to
park enhancement in with it motion moved
in seconded I'll ask you to vote for
next all those in favor please raise
your right hand in against Tony I'd like
my boat recorded as being opposed thank
you thank you sir I just wanted to
clarify not everybody who voted what you
worship did you for or against Annette
my ocean place no I thought I shouldn't
vote on it because I didn't hear that
a lot my brother called freezer miss
Jefferson thank you worship so just to
clarify those against who would want the
rock Hort the votes recorded was council
o'clock councillor arnold in counselor a
bit have you got that Lonnie thank you
thank you James so we'll move on to the
next item on our agenda which is number
five emergency water supply update or in
progress Tony
honey just as one side issue given the
decisions made made now how does counsel
you can communicating their outcome back
to the audit our community thank you
yes look at Michelle sorry could you
please repeat that Christian oh sorry
Michelle given that we had quite a large
meeting by out-of-towner standards and
given it it's quite a been put into US
and I've had people chasing me for the
results how do you intend to communicate
back to community that the outcome that
we've got and one possible suggestion
could be that we put round a one-page
flyer that could be circulated into the
Otara rd nine mile system that is good
people but not date on on the on the
decisions that we've made today yep I've
been really happy to do that especially
given the community meeting that has
been held in advance so details about
that okay
thank you thank you catalyst I will move
now to the next item which is obviously
the water it up I will hand you over to
Ellis that I'm assuming on it one thank
you sir Thank You councillor Biddle this
report has been prepared at the request
of their chair of infrastructure and
services counselor Pottinger just to
update councillors and keep them in
touch with this project in Vacarro has
been looking for or as a strategic
objective of stablishing an alternative
water supply to diminish its risk and
vulnerability should its main supply
that see really breaks on scheme fail
for a reason
most would supplies in throughout New
Zealand of the comparable size from UK
will have more than one supply
Invercargill has the one and the Cargill
and Bluff headers only the one supply so
should it fail
would be in catastrophic circumstances
so a long term plan has
made provision for a development of a
alternative supply direct for
emergencies midway through this decade
and it is anticipated that the best will
supply to counter our current risk and
be at least cost is that which would
come from an underground source so we
have made some progress towards that
investigation Council in its collective
contribution with all other self and
councils entered into a exercise which
was convened by the then venture
Southland to carry out a survey of the
southern region for not just water
supply but for mineral exploration in
for seismic faulting which gave an
indication that the word groundwater
sources that would be suitable council
then after receiving report from local
experts committed to phases one and two
of what was a four phase investigation
study those phases were flip-phone phase
one and phase two were to estimate the
water treatment that might be required
from underground water source and also
model it to where would be the best
places to look for it because as you can
appreciate putting bores down long for
water supply is just like prospecting
for any underground material be it gold
coal oil was just the same there's quite
an element of risk towards incurring
huge costs if we don't use the best
knowledge available to look for that
underground source
so we've now received report back from
phases one and two they are provisional
only because council in an earlier
meeting much of last year I believe
resolved to have those reports of phase
one and two peer reviewed before
before going towards consideration so
the results that I my report is
provisional on this report and so much
said it hasn't been peer reviewed but
really what it says is that the water
that's likely to come from an
underground supply here in south and
will require treatment because it's
likely that we'll have manganese and
possibly iron which you'll have to
remove the reason will cost associated
with that
I might add - secondly that there's
probably four places that warrant
further investigation as to the location
of where we might find this source they
are in the our ruler Plains
coincidentally where we have a rather
large land holding at the moment it was
set aside for industrial development the
confluence of the metro area RET River
and possibly the Meyers Reserve which is
close by a major reservoir and pump
station that was put in mainly because
it was very very convenient if we were
able to find a source which is close to
our existing infrastructure so the
recommendation is that we proceed
forward getting peer reviewed but
getting the report on phase one and to
peer reviewed and bring it back to
Council for its consideration I'll take
any questions if there are any counts
left sorry could you wish up the Mia and
lean counts and their clack was that
counsel Arnold that hit his hand up to
this excuse me politeness madam chair I
see a few technical problems it it just
seems to me every counselor that sit
through at some stage someone will raise
the issue of that water supply and we
haven't covered contact in the case of
emergencies and
and they all come down to the same issue
is that the the cost is so prohibitive
and the quality is debatable you know
it's I mean when I got on here was the
Iroko apartments the big gate but wind
council as the skeleton to be over 20
million dollars which is a lot of money
in those days and they seemed to sort of
back away from it rather quickly and I
think we I'm wondering whether it's
worth looking at alternative systems
like getting all the water trucks
registered in Southland and just
something that's cheap and not a hundred
percent what we wanted but at least we
had a system in place for a fire or a
severe drought and it could be based
around Waikele it or however it's just
my view on the subject anyway yes
councillors the major threat I think for
the Invercargill Brinks on duty supply
is drought now if we are to protect
ourselves against that really a local
River supply is not going to address it
the underground source was thought to be
the best solution towards that in so
much that it's not affected by drought
in the same way that a river source
would be it's also the least cost option
the lake supply will it be by hiroko or
wakatipu back in the year 2000 was
estimated in excess of 50 million
dollars so though they are very
expensive sources
the underground supply even though
treatment may or may not be required if
we want to just take in a space form
store it resents the least cost option
bear in mind - we are only in engaging
an investigative works to try and size
and look at the feasibility of an
alternative supply we are not yet
committing to developing it so this
exercise is just purely to complete
investigation works or underground
acting as an emergency water supply
thank you for that
sorry if I'm in this tree counselor
clack sorry it cuts were clapping
counselor sofa my apologies Alistair
just a couple of issues I recall a
couple of years ago the council approved
$50,000 $50,000 toward drilling and I
guess what I'm hearing from you now that
it's of no value to go drilling it's a
little bit like prospecting that you
just sort of a stab in the dark so you
said using that we haven't done any that
would give any drilling that's correct
more recently Council agreed that we
should really try and obtain the best
information we could before committing
to on-site work such as drilling because
drilling is very expensive and if that's
not done it's far better to obtain
expert advice using their best
information available to guide us and
our source for an underground supply its
sophisticated prospecting as opposed to
just putting down bores on cloak we all
say so severe water supplies are it's
likely that our supply is from a deeper
source than that which has currently
being experienced by farm bores and most
of the boards that have been used around
south and the cable was on a boar supply
until the late 1950s and what's now
called the Gore lignite measures but
towards the end of that that time
the the yield was was the amount of
water we obtain was diminishing
someone's colloquial the description was
to like sucking water out of a lump of
clay so you want to be able to find a
source that's going to give us a
sufficient yield and also be a best
quality possible-- southland is not like
the our um the Canterbury Plains who are
very lucky to obtain water from from the
mountains and there's something else
through gravel deposits which allow
water to run rather freely south endures
not like that it's a much more
restricted and poorer quality water
likely to be from around the ground
source and the second question what area
I noticed that you mentioned the
possibility of piping water from lake
wakatipu what other Lakes and I've put a
play proper Reni through the council
from a member of public that suggested
that we should look at the option of
pate of piping from mano y mano y being
raffia three times the distance of the
pipe that we've got going to bluff he
said that and literally as you reflect
on these projects are very expensive
upwards of fifty million dollars but
back in the day when it was costed those
pipelines were predominantly concrete
and asbestos mix and the the plastic
ones that we can use now are much
cheaper to install and easier to
maintain so is that still an option that
we could be looking to I would disagree
about the cost of pipelines in today's
will being less and what it was say
twenty thirty years ago I think they
still still an expensive item to put in
and you might just prefer to our rents
on pipeline renewal of eleven million
dollars of some ten kilometres in length
putting pipelines through a great
distance is a very expensive exercise
that's why an underground source close
to our community is thought to be the
most
most effective I can't recall whether we
looked at mono I as a source I know that
Hiroko and Walker took were that if I
went back and into the records I might
be able to find some information on
whether or not one or why it was
considered I'm sorry I can't give you
that in fact that's right thank you
Thank You councillor Clark thinking
Alistair our councillors Soper thanks
madam Chia
first of all it's a very appreciative of
the report from the update I just wanted
to go back to the geophysical material
we were originally provided with when we
started the process of starting this
investigation and just reflect that the
Chatham formation in the geophysical
material we got at that time seemed to
be probably the best the best possible
way we could proceed at the time and and
one of the more exciting geophysical
pieces of material to come out for some
time so I'm quite pleased to have the
update and to know that now we're just
waiting from the peer review I think
that phase one and two was well worth
doing because if we if we didn't explore
the check and formation I think we would
be doing probably the public of the
cable but also of the whole of South
from the butter but the service by not
looking at that really exciting looking
option and so I'm I'm really clean that
we young that we receive your report and
that we we wait for that dumb
peer-review to come through and then see
where we're going to proceed from the
year so yeah basically thanks for the
report I still think it's a an exciting
exploration to have undertaken and the
peer review thank you thank you cancer
sacra I'm assuming from there you're
moving that those recommendations thank
you and I'm moving to council public
jack thanks Tony I think Alastair
touched on an important part of this
project is risk and
and what the biggest risk is and without
a doubt is the supply so whether it be
drought or a contamination of the river
that that put it out of action now that
risk would also have to take him to
affect how long would it be out of
action for and we can analyze these
things we can look at how long
potentially would a drought last and
three years ago it got quite scary and
then a rain thank God
and everything was finding you but this
is a real problem and we need
Dooney just sort it out so in my mind is
the supply and how long would we need
the supply for before they're ready was
back in action again that's the key
thing because you go to the extreme of
running a pipeline to a lake well your
Mosel cancel your ET project out all you
hear that and just take the water from
there so little own resource consent so
I really I've got no no favor and
contemplating pursuing any of those
ideas but the underground water that
would have to get to our treatment
station because it's no point in
building a second treatment station the
other risks that our hand would be an
earthquake and if we got a pipeline
break or from brain summons town now
we'd have to look at how long
potentially there appear that would take
a night Dallas that would probably have
an idea of of those sort of things and I
imagined that we would have contingency
plans people on maybe standby to eat
those things fixed
so this project really I see to move
forward to I think Alice to see that
five years time or I'm not sure when
that in the LTP but that second second
underground supply which without a doubt
is the only option has has to through
these studies be found and if you can
get the pipeline to get the brakes on
and a reasonable cost so our Ruhr as a
mention in the paper would ever come all
the way past the city
back again so now I see that it's maybe
the third option but the risk is the
risk to to get sorted is that supply
from already and I back up one so that's
what this whole project is about not
reinventing the wheel that's my comment
Thank You councillor Pottenger I have a
mover for those recommendations is there
anyone I haven't a stick in there sorry
was it I've got a minute but about six
hands out there now so I'll take it was
it your worship did you want to seek a
new motion was that you yep okay so
moved and seconded all those in favor of
those recommendations on the report
please raise your right hand
thank you against Thank You counselors
carries it's great time thank you
I'm moving to in honest I think you
alistair for your time today see you're
waving us goodbye thank you council is
moving to item number six which is our
rates right is for July to wean tea - OH
- OH - July 21 obviously I just remind
you with hints of workshops a huge
amount of information and quite a bit of
robust discussion amongst us in so I
welcome that discussion back to the
table today this report has been done is
a result of that's relaxed released from
last meeting that we give our community
a direction about where we anticipate
and we go with the rates rise and so I'm
gonna pass the report take it as read in
ask David Foster to speak to this please
thank you madam - do you mind if I share
my screen I'll just run through the
powerpoints that we've run through in
the past slightly updated to come back
to - the rationale for why thank you
goodness gracious I got so many things
open here
so obviously the thing that sort of
thrown the spanner in the works for all
the things in regards to our plan
because we're we're of course going to
be up for public consultation on it by
now and then a rethink decided well
let's go back to year three of the LTP
so the things that have impacted
obviously Cobert 19 and following on the
expect of economic fallout from that
which people are predicting is likely to
be too through you maybe even four years
long items that we've down to respond to
that as a postponement of rates you'll
notice that there's an awful lot going
on in the media about capital spend and
general economic theory runs down the
track that whenever you go into a
recession the public sector should XE
start capital spending because capital
spend leads to jobs it also enables
infrastructure to be built often in a
recession you find that because these
levels of unemployment it's a good time
to go out and do capital work because it
can be cheaper and finally there's the
one on rates because you will be aware
that at one stage we were talking about
a rates rise as high as six percent and
we've gone back clearly to you there so
the big thing we're running into and the
mix of it is is a significant level of
uncertainty that that's really rocking
the status quo so at the moment there's
so much movement is somewhat difficult
to base a reliable prediction on what's
going to happen so therefore our plans
need to be far more flexible so in doing
that we've got to be able to respond to
a number of things but the economists
are picking a significant rise in
unemployment as high as 10 percent I
heard something yesterday that was
saying that a thousand people around the
country are registering for the
unemployment benefit every day and so
that's starting to become very real the
other one I've referred to in the past
the element from
Shamu belly quad all of the things that
he has been talking about going on and
while people talk about reductions in
gross domestic product and so on we've
got to remember that the hits that are
going to come from this are going to be
to the individuals the the GDP is a
summary measure of what's happening in
regards to individual households and
businesses and the key suggestion that's
coming out from most people is be very
generous to those people who are really
struggling and so therefore building the
capacity and the flexibility to be more
generous to those who are really
struggling groveler then giving a small
amount across the board to everybody so
GDP is as I so simply to sum where this
flows into to thinking about the annual
plan is wage inflation is going to fall
now we had predicted around about two
percent two point three percent for wage
inflation flowing through into the
long-term plan so that was factored into
our three and a half percent growth
interest rates are still falling
compared to our LTP and economists are
picking that they're going to stay low
for longer and a reason for that is to
say the government of lower the OCR and
the predictions are that it will stay
low there's even talk now or rumors that
it may go into negative we won't go into
that but it is an example of how low
they're looking to take it the other one
that we're going to run into more people
will struggle to pay their rates through
unemployment and other bits coming in
and different communities will have
different impacts so this is going to
impact on us difference too to say
Queenstown but also within our community
we're almost certain to see that
different parts of our community are
going to be affected differently also
CPI so general inflation across the
board is going to be lower so with fact
that our two
the two and a half percent increases for
inflation we've looked at some of the
stuff that's coming out of the economic
predictions they are talking about it
being lower certainly for a period of
time so we've modified that back to one
and then coming up into the future so
our response to it is that we're going
to run and reduce the rates rise from
from what we were talking about take it
lower we're going to run budget deficit
so in the past we've talked about
section 100 where it says that local
authorities must set their revenues to
cover their costs this is a time really
where we we do need to respond to the
fact that things are going to be more
difficult for our community so therefore
we are factoring in to run budget
deficits and we're going to advance our
capital works program and Council have
had conversations about advance and the
capital work program really since about
April last year building in all of the
things that weren't included in the LTP
but which we're being talked about at
the LTP time we're going to borrow more
the level of borrowing that we're going
to be talking about probably two years
out is going to impact on our credit
rating now we're probably likely to see
ourselves come back into line more with
other councils at the moment we were one
of about three councils at the highest
credit rating as we come more into line
with averages which we're talking about
within here that's going to knock our
credit rating a little bit fifteen see
one or two notches which may lead to a
little bit higher cost of deep for us
and one of the things again that came
from Gemma Bell's work was that a
million dollars less rates is worth
about eight and a half jobs whereas a
million dollars more money spent on
interest is worth 150 jobs or more
depending on the interest rate and and
with them that obviously more spend
equals more jobs and hence why general
economic theory is that the public
sector should be doing capital
at this time because it does generate
jobs we've already talked about their
rates postponement policy it's out now
soon be out for public consultation and
I won't get too much into the element of
why remit not remotely as opposed to
postpone we've had that conversation and
one of the keys though for us in terms
of why not go for a zero rates rise is
actually the relationship between rates
capital spending and borrowing we know
because we've talked about it that our
borrowing capacity is 2.5 times out
rittany so if we were to reduce our
revenue by a million dollars say that's
it's two and a half million dollars that
we can't borrow right so it's actually
having a compounding effect in terms of
the capital work programs that we can do
so they keep the spending going we
actually need to make sure that we've
got enough revenue coming in to be able
to do that and also for it to be
sustainable borrowing we know borrowings
constrained by the 2.5 times multiplier
that's a factor that's set by our main
funder which is the local government
funding agency and they have an element
where if you go for a credit rate of
council which we are if we go above 2.5
times we can't borrow from them anymore
which means we have to go to the market
and nobody's prepared to go over that
because actually that's the point at
which the conventional thinking is that
that's starting to become unworkable
hence why it's been selected at 2.5
times and the other thing that's
important for thinking about rates is
actually that has an ongoing impact so
it's not just one year if you go with a
lower rates rise and you've got a lower
rates level every year going out by that
much so again coming back we've got a
balanced rates capital work we're doing
more capital work we're going to raise
our debt so the capital works going to
be funded by debt it's going to be less
funded by rates because we're talking
about rates rises so we
got to keep their balance in here hence
why we're saying don't go with a zero
right thrust and to give you a number
zero rates rise would mean you would
have to trim sixteen million dollars off
the next ten years capital work program
and if you're going to do that you're
going to have to trim it from the nicer
to have capital works because you can't
trim it off the renewals if you're going
to trim it off the renewals and we're
going to run into all sorts of problems
part do with auditors in terms of a
robust sustainable LTP and to give you
an idea our capital work program is
roughly four hundred million over
thirteen years it's the revised one that
we've been doing our projections on
three hundred million of that is and
renewals so the amount of money that
you've got for the nicer to have such as
the inner city the ACI Museum renewals
those sorts of things they are a hundred
million so if you're going to go add a
zero rates rise you're going to have to
trim that capital work program by
sixteen percent that's fairly sizable
central government and one of the
ministers have recently made an
announcement that council should not go
for a zero rates for us and expect the
government to backfill it the government
is looking for councils obviously did do
their part in terms of the recovery and
that extra means prepared to Co fund but
we have to be able to pay away now our
LTP for this year was three and a half
percent the following two years of five
percent plus five percent so we're
effectively talking about fourteen
percent rates rise over the next three
years and so in that context if you were
to go with zero at what point do you
recover it
we've already talked about how much zero
is so what we're modeling is effectively
that two percent is a significant
reduction
2% is going to be a stretch for us
probably for the next three years but it
is a possibility so I'm running at this
side model will actually 2% running out
for a number of years it's tight it's
incredibly tight and it would require
significant amounts of efficiencies and
tightening the belt to be made but we
have looked at that so 2 percent as a
sustainable rates rise for the next 2 to
3 years it's workable I'm trying to find
how I can and share my screen I've got
the model available but I'm not sure
necessarily that we need to go through
that one of the things that is
significant in in terms of the modeling
is the extent to which a zero rates rise
blows our deficits out of the water so
at the moment we're modeling around
about 17 million dollars of deficits 14
years it slowly recovers if you go with
zero rates rise you're going to
effectively blow that number up to about
30 million dollars in deficits and 30
million dollars in deficits is going to
create problems so really one of the
major issues with zero is it's not
sustainable at some point you're going
to have to recover it this is not a
one-year issue that we're going through
it's a multi-year issue
most people are predicting that this is
going to go long and deep we've already
had a bit of conversation about that so
whatever we do we've actually got to be
measured in terms of that response we
have modeled 2% as being sort of
workable it's going to take quite a bit
of work for us all collectively to go
through and do that the chief executive
has already highlighted that as a
possibility for us to be working through
so I'll leave it there madam - any
questions obviously happy birthday
Thank You mr. Foster I just have one
question before I ask for any more the
efforts rate take for us and the Cargill
what is that roughly in an in percentage
what would the average person be in
monetary amount value for people for
public sir I think the average was about
two thousand one hundred and forty four
dollars per annum is right yes I was
trying to I was trying to work that
through it was about that I did that
calculation and forwarded that to you
thank you
it is around two thousand one hundred
and fifty as you say plus or minus some
five or ten dollars two percent of that
clearly would be fourteen dollars forty
two dollars a year and so that's what 80
cents a week questions for mr. Foster my
questions councilís thank you just one
quick question don't just for everybody
um just could you explain why again just
quickly why not use some of the cash in
the bank you know that we've gotten
reserves for renewal works I think in in
the mix of it councilors we've already
fected all of that in all right if you
recall when we go back we've talked
about net it
and so net debt to remind people what
that is net debt is the amount of money
that we've drawn down and loans less the
amount of money that we've got sitting
on the bank all of our ratios are
calculated on the neat debt announced
but you have a preference for drawing
down loans one is a little bit more
obvious but the in terms of what you're
doing and where you're going there
second though is that if we spend the
money that we've got in the bank then we
this interest if we only interest then
we fictive Li have two and a half times
that impact of how much money we can
borrow right so a million dollars coming
in as income is worth two and a half
million dollars of additional borrowing
head room for the capital work program
that we're talking about so well it's
tempting to use the money we are going
to go very very close to to hitting our
capital will get very mobile you see
we're not going to go over we will
manage it the closer we get the tighter
we get and the more it is going to
restrict your decisions going forward so
the modeling is effectively putting us
very very close within sort of five
million dollars of our of our deep caps
in year three plus we start to come back
if we were to use the money that we've
got an investment so deep cap would drop
more and we would overlap whereas if we
were to use Dietz and keep our money
invested we just maintain that slight
difference in terms of this so hence why
not use the cash maybe respond to
fantastic clack you know two things I
guess and fully support what you said
and and that comes as a surprise to some
people
imitating for zero rates for quite some
time well listen to the information you
put up and certainly listen to what
scheme' being scared to say and I think
the a modest rate increase which seems
to be at the lower end of what other
councils are doing is the way forward
and doesn't undermine our ability to do
some project work in the next two or
three years
just one quick issue for you though I
just want you know reiterate something
for me was he said that we at the moment
about about a hundred million dollars
under our potential cap with the local
government funding agencies there right
so we've got that sort of you know bail
then I go oh do you think that will
improve air
for cars going forward will be improved
by the crown infrastructure helping to
fund some of the work that we were
looking to do ourselves yeah the crown
infrastructure would help a lot a it
brings in a little bit more revenue it's
not really going to count in terms of
your debt caps because it's sort of one
offering you that you can't rely on so
typically its factored back out by
almost every analyst that looks at it
but clearly if the government are going
to assist then we will have more
Headroom but I'm certain that the
council in the community going forward
will have projects that we have not yet
even dreamed of and I think that's a key
issue about not going to close to the
debt cap if you recall in the last LTP
there are a significant number of
capital items some big some small that
weren't included in the work program
partly because of timing and you know
different thoughts Council wasn't in the
decision in place to make those
decisions and although we try and put
our best foot forward in terms of
thinking about what's coming up we'll
never get all yeah and against like you
said we potentially have government
ceiling issues around water anyway but
you can still come down the track dude
okay you appreciate the work you've done
on it thank you council is so pad and
I'm just wanting to signal is there any
other councillors have a question yeah
right it's probably not so much a
question is just to say today thank you
for the work date I must admit I was
very concerned when people started
talking about zero rates rises what that
would do you to air ability as a council
to be part of the local simulation that
would be necessary when it was becoming
more and more obvious what was going to
happen with the the length of time we
might be in crisis in the effect on jobs
so so to me
seemed important that we had the balance
and flexibility of not putting ourselves
in a position where we blew out deficits
and didn't give them a rate percentage
that gave us the ability to take part in
the economic recovery I think we've got
to acknowledge that we have got that
role as community leaders and also that
responsibility to be prudent in the way
we we manage not just for today but
thinking very much of the future that in
2050 year out time so I'm pretty happy
with with what you've presented I think
congratulations to you and your team on
the research that's gone onto it I feel
that that you are giving us a
recommendation that's got the balance
struck in yeah I just like to say thank
you very much for all the work that's
gone into it to you and your whole team
councillor Soper and what they don't
mind I guess with I'm really confident
that we've put those policies in place
for those and had to be taken care of
and I think that was probably the
biggest priority for the table when we
last spoke I think it's also time that
we have to show some pretty brave
leadership because I know that a zero
increase across the community has been
something that a lot of people have
signaled but when you are confronted
with all the information and you do have
a lot of information in time to consider
we really responsible for almost
restarting our economy down here so I
think we have to play a very mess of
part and generating lots of capital work
for jobs jobs jobs and we've been you
know challenged we have challenged the
offices of information over two or three
workshops now sorry two workshops in a
meeting so with that in mind I will ask
if there's anyone who would be happy to
move the recommendation on mr. Foster's
report you know take them all is one
before I ask for hands sorry if you've
already popped them up there the report
rates rise for July 22 21 financial year
being received that the rates rise for
the year commits in 1 July to be seated
2 percent in that the rates rise applies
evenly to all right types to ensure that
individual ratepayers would have rates
increase closely relating to the tree be
seen in that the actual striking of the
rates which is really important will
occur after the adoption of the in your
plane and it council notes that we the
property has been improved or developed
since 30 June 2019 a different rates
rises may occur which is all normal
in standard but just on it mr. Foster if
you could just give us some
communication around that last
recommendation for people who are
obviously watching the livestream is it
all possible place the reason for having
that and councils have been criticised
in the past will be talk about having a
rates rise and then somebody opens the
envelope and they find that councils
talk about 2% and all of a sudden they
get a an increase which was hired a
minute what we've got coming out of the
Rickett the third recommendation is that
if you haven't done anything to your
property such as an extension any
changes which involved building those
items when they come through they change
your valuation so they change what your
property is being rated on so really
what we're saying is that if you haven't
had any work like that done and nothing
has happened to change your rating value
since when it was done three years ago
then your rates rise will be 2 percent
plus or minus tiny fractions if you have
had work done you are going to pay more
or potentially less so potentially if
you've gone through and demolished part
of the property then of course your pay
less but if you've built a new house
built a new unit extendo Gera
something along those lines you will
have higher rates rise because the value
of your property is higher
that's what thank you mr. foster in has
wished you sorry to contradict you when
you've got such a high level of support
but I we were told that it didn't matter
how much because this valuation system
would always stir up a lot of people and
a lot of negative thoughts because the
feeling was that they had done all the
jobs you see it put on a patio put in a
glass house painted the roof but it made
no difference and we said why was that
and we were told that how that works is
that they look at the three houses in
your street or in your area and see what
they recently sold for and the valuation
of your properties got nothing to do
with how well they looked after it it's
a need to do with the value in
relationship to your neighbors or your
neighborhood properties is that system
change now now I think the the issue you
worship as one is talking about what
happens during our full revaluation and
counselors do to have a full revaluation
of all of the properties in the district
that's due for the following rating year
now so we're currently working through
with quotable value and the value of
general as to the date on which that
will occur so partly even if you've done
work on your house if you've done work
on your house that you don't require a
building consent for around maintenance
so for instance painting of your house
typically doesn't add to its capital
value it may well add to its
marketability and its sell ability but
typically that is regarded as
maintenance and doesn't add we're on the
other hand you've added significantly to
your property where you require a
building consent in data
the point at which a revaluation will be
done which may or may not change your
property value some of them they will go
through and say well it does others it
doesn't but I mean clearly one that
clearly does is if you've had your
property and you've effectively made
your house twice the size that it was
before then you can expect that your
property value is going to rise through
that work Thank You mr. foster think you
worship mr. Kidd yeah sorry for joining
the meeting very late meeting and I'll
have to leave in shortly but I had an L
the right buyer he's got a house on
property and Windsor bending around
about four hundred and fifty thousand
dollars he's has very little cash but
he's asset rich right houses asset for a
house barely around 450,000 mr. foster
what would his dollar increases from
zero rates increased at a two percent
increase what with roughly with it cost
him extra a year on a house worth
wondering I'm sorry I can give those
details to you but I haven't got the
details at that particular level but I
can calculate it and get it to you even
if see where the above the air birds but
our big yeah yeah yep Peter this will
work at this because people have asked
me a same thing as well so if somebody
had a house with a with a rain'll value
about about that amount he's probably
going to pay about 80 cents a week more
80 cents yeah
grand a better figure yeah so I've
worked it okay I just came across finish
your work yeah and Everett would be
between 60 and 70 now when I tuned in I
heard Dave say Nate and so I'm happy
with it one other question today
how many right pies have we got and
total like how many commercial
ratepayers and how many residential
ratepayers
just roughly wing-t yeah we've got
roughly 25,000 all emailed to you the
proportions yeah okay thank you
Thank You councillor Keith thank you
Dave I just wanted to clarify did I have
a move there in a second delay me for
the emotions those motions no I haven't
so I would be happy to move those
recommendations Thank You councillor
mags seconded by councillor cricket
thank you all those in favor of those
recommendations that I read out prior
please raise your right hand
I've got 12 a 13 Thank You counselors
it's a great outcome moving now to item
number 7 which is our final item in
public which is our financial reporting
in our take a bit too Dave mr.foster
place thank thank you madam chair I
won't go through this and in a lot of
detail and rather than doing two
presentations at the meeting I thought
with this just to do the one for the
rates the council's position is quite a
bit better than our last review and so
this was a factor that I did give some
consideration around the rates rise and
so on as to where we're at and in fact
her and where we're at with this the key
thing I think with this is what we've
got coming through here is a level of
increased revenue through low council
driven we're really effectively selling
an asset that we haven't in the past
being able to realize so the lion's
share of the increase
we've got in the surplus is coming from
additional money paid to us by our
subsidiaries and that is from a thing
that's called a subvention payments and
pardon me for getting quite technical
but a submission payment is effectively
where a company that is in a group has a
profit it pays tax on that profit to the
IRD subvention payments are a thing
which allows them to pay money to
another party in the group and for that
payment to then become tax-deductible
and for that to help to eliminate their
tax loss so what we're doing here is our
tax losses have been used to stop them
paying tax so obviously we have a
limited amount of tax losses so in the
mix of what we've got coming in there is
effectively a one-off or at least we
might be able to get some next year but
it's not going to be an ongoing level or
even year particularly to that extent so
in the mix of it also in doing the
forecasts the the team were really quite
difficult to do a forecast when you're
in the middle of a lockdown and then
you're going to alert level 3
I'm sorry I'm not sure what's happened
here me stat sig music it's that's my
granddaughter trying to ring grant dead
ends for kind of photo ID me all my
devices are linked so everything goes
when it goes so in the mix with with
that uncertainty so what they've done is
they've done a range of scenarios and
I'm on on page 38 of the agenda in terms
of thinking about what things can look
like and what the impacts so what the
team have done is a good look at what
can happen in regards to coming out of
the code that lockdowns
economic elements all of that stuff that
can happen so the predictions with God
as effectively we've gone at four
million as we've forecast but that's
probably the most favorable from there
we look at ranges that take us through
two three point four and three point
three scenario one effectively says
we're in level four then level three
then legal - we go quite quickly through
those at about a month each scenario -
which is interesting because I had to go
back to the team to tell me why are
these numbers different was looking at a
4-3-3 where we're and that's the alert
levels room the reason that the orange
bar goes up is it in a certain scenario
we can harvest the forestry whereas if
we're in a four for three or four three
three
we can't harvest the forestry so that
makes a difference in the mix there so
at this stage although we've got four
and there's in terms of circumstance the
range is going to be three to four and
it's highly likely to being around that
three point three we're looking to do
work in the mix of it as - on the
efficiencies and getting various other
initiatives up and running that we need
to get up and running by the 30th of
June so that we're all said to be really
running quite hard once we get into the
new financial year and so I won't go any
further on that and I like that turret
in full element most of it you've seen
sorry I've just remembered one thing we
haven't covered that we do need to cover
is the capital work spend so you'll see
in there on page 40 our prediction is
that the capital works pin will be 20
million compared to the 39.9 that
excludes by the way the capitalization
of ICL and that's because while we
factor it into capital for our and
modeling technically it's an investment
so it doesn't sit within the capital
work program within here so 39.2 is now
going to be 20 million obviously the
reason for being that low compared to
the other is covert being unlocked down
and coming back out of the lockdown and
when that is going to occur because
there's going to be some lead time in
terms of tenders being related contracts
being lit and and people getting
established on site so I'll leave it
there madam-ji thank you mr. Foster
um any questions of mr. Foster around
the phone intros Thank You Clark
two things Dave and one of them may be
ours answered by Darren Edwards but in
the report yeah I noticed in the Capitol
area that you affect Randall's signaling
a potential cost of 1.7 million dollars
with a capital expenditure towards
Anderson's house well how what our
financial position improve if the final
report on Anderson's house the terms
that we actually don't need to do any
strengthening work clearly I think with
Anderson house we're not forecasting
Anderson house being done but my
recollection from the reporters is
actually that we're forecasting it was
in the 39 but it's not in the 20 okay
that work would would almost certainly
not be able to get tendered
and speaks in this year I guess the
other issue is the issue of the traffic
lights I noticed that we have ongoing
against performance issues in the
regulatory area which is Darren's area
and I appreciate that these had
increased revenue coming from their
servicing and certainly increased
demands and this report is the end of
March and not not where we're at at the
moment say and then also I understand
that these are implemented a an
electronic system that helps track track
concedes through the system so can
somebody give me some update on how
those performance issues are likely to
improve is there something on the
horizon for that or we still straming
the earlier it be to do that Dave thanks
for the question I mean something that I
discussed with councilor Arnold earlier
today so but building consents has been
something of a challenge for us for a
number of years now as we continue to
process paper applications as they come
across the desk earlier this year we
moved into electronic lodgement through
simply which is a front-end I guess of
gogit which allows us to do our
inspections electronically so what we
are starting to see is the sorry issuing
of the consents within 20 days a
hovering between the 95 to hundred
percent mark we've seen that
consistently through a level four and
previously just as we came into a
Louisville 4 so I'm confident that when
we see the fourth quarter results that
there'll be some improvement there
looks like year-to-date is 59% I'd be
I'd be optimistically thinking that
would be somewhere in the mid to late
80s for the year noting that we've only
got a quarter to allow for improved
okay we think that Darren I mean I know
it's near attention and certainly if
there's improvement see that's certainly
heading in the right direction doesn't
it you're still still influenced by the
boy by having vacancies in your team is
that still an issue yeah get it that's a
it's a good question and so in when you
when we look at the numbers that we've
got barring a recent retirement which is
only Friday the team is it's got two
vacancies which obviously when we come
out of the alert levels and back to some
form of normality we'll we'll look at
that also noting that is going to be a
lot of consultancy out there who are
wanting to guarantee some form shape of
work for themselves so the market I
would think will be fairly active as far
as recruitment so confident that we'll
be able to pick up some really really
qualified people here and also at the
same time really happy with the level of
service that we are getting from
building solutions who is the consultant
dealing with the applications in pushing
through the consents so they're the
target against legislative days is a
hundred percent and it's consistently
been a hundred percent for the past few
very much march/april since we've come
into the early levels and of course all
of that is cost recovered just just two
quick questions on that last comment
that you made using the consultants they
said is it I'm not trying to trick you
is that I am a cost that would be hired
consent than it would be if if we were
using internal staffing and secondly I
think that sometime early you might have
commented on the fact or your
predecessor might accommodate on the
fact that even though the Christchurch
firm were doing some work for us
the final sign-off still set within this
office within our structure for those
two situations still prevalent for you
yep sure so the rate that we've
negotiated with Building Solutions
it's extremely competitive I'm sure as
you can appreciate it guaranteed them
tenure of work through the alert levels
so happy with with that rate cost
recovered through the applicant so it's
no it's no higher than what you would
see coming out the door if we were
processing them Building Solutions
allows us to have this legislatively
building competency across all levels so
from your small residential build right
up to your complex commercial so they're
able to provide the full suite of
competencies for us we are still signing
them off when they come back into into
Council so they'll come with a strong
recommendation supporting the approval
or the decline and what we've done we've
changed our process to ensure that we
are getting them out quicker and they
come back to us from building solutions
so so what last question is just one of
the issues that that was suggested by
your predecessor was that
mamie Building Solutions would in the
future be in a position to do the
approvals therein so that there wasn't
this backwards and forwards in where
they come to come to your team but then
your team go back to building services
and potentially want more information or
more process done is that something
you're still looking towards if so again
the change and practice for us hasn't
negated the need to do that okay
excellent Thanks
welcome Thank You councillor Clark Thank
You Darren it was this is such a good
update that we've received today because
I do know that the council chamber was
very ambitious they wanted to see some
changes happen yesterday so great great
outcome
um councillors I'm just wanting to take
you back to the report on the table
which is our financial and wanting to
know if anyone is able or willing to
move that we receive that report there
is the only recommendation on the report
so I'd be happy to move that if
someone's happy to seek in there
Thank You councillor Lewis all those in
favor raise your right hand
thank you against carries Thank You
counselors that brings us to the end of
our public meeting in the livestream so
I'm going to ask that we take about two
or three minute break on mute this
allows time for the public to the
livestream to stop in henan Walden give
us an indication she's waving at me for
a five-minute no no I'm sorry I would
like to suggest that you formally move
in and vote and to go into public
excluded that was all I was going to
suggest before I do so I'll move by
Councillor super seconded by Councillor
abbott that we move into public excluded
all those in favor please raise your
right hand
all those against motion carries thank
you very much and thank you to the
public for watching our livestream
exciting livestream today of our meeting
counselors we'll just take five minutes
in min little allow us time to go into
public excluded if you just all mute
yourself before you wander away